would you
[Music]
would you move into a house do you know
someone died in no yeah
you know if it's a [ __ ] way oh okay
hold on it depends
how did they die
because if it because if they die from
like natural causes yeah sure oh my god
but if it's like a brutal murder then no
it okay but why though why it is
literally all known oh my god what the
[ __ ] that looks like a dark souls
dungeon
that is literally where the final boss
lays
that's [ __ ] horrible that's the end
game
man
jesus i didn't imagine the skulls being
a part of the equation i thought it was
just like bones tibias and [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] hell no like so
you would happily move into a house
where someone got murdered oh god yeah
really if we get if i'm getting a deal
on this yeah yeah yeah yeah i'll be at
the [ __ ] at them at the meeting with
them being like oh i don't know
10 10 percent off it's a little
someone did die
maybe 15 20 off
how about how low would you willingly be
willing to go like how much would you
negotiate down if you knew someone had
died in this house i tried to get a
third off
because like that's actually a pretty
big thing in japan isn't it not not
people getting brutally murdered but
like
like houses where people have died of
natural causes
in this market you can't be picky you've
got to take what you can get
that is right
i'll be like who died
there's a website actually uh which is
like a real estate website where it
tells you uh which houses are on sale of
like they call it
accident uh apartments uh where some
horrible uh some horrible accident has
happened and now it's on sale why would
that affect your view of the apartment
or the house though it's like it's like
if i it's like saying oh if someone had
used that swing and died on it would you
would you not want to use it
well probably not
is it because it's it's because they
lived there is that what like adds the
weight to it i don't to me i don't
to me like a house is just
personal you know it's like it's it's
like your purse it's not a house it's a
home
that's true that's true but like the
only but you're to me it's like what
makes a home is the you know the way
that you've made it yours right it's
like the base walls and floors don't
mean [ __ ] to me but all my stuff that's
my couch that's my tv and i put it there
that's what makes it
me
to me to me at least so when you know
that's why when i move into an apartment
i'm not like well it's weird someone
used to live here i'm like oh they just
it's a box no no i don't think that of
like someone used to live here but
there's a big difference between oh
someone lived here for 30 years and oh
uh
that guy was dead there a couple of
years ago like brutally
i don't i'm not okay with that
yeah i don't know it's it's if it's not
there anymore it's just like it's like
you're moving here and it's like don't
mind the dead guys
well it's like you know having your uh
what was it like it i i guess goes back
into pilings like superstition i think
it's it's it's a it's a how you know i'm
not
real estate
originally like sometimes when houses
were really cheap in japan here i would
go and looks i'm like there's no way
that's this cheap yeah and then you'd go
online you would see
occasionally that actually someone had
passed in there yeah yeah yeah but you
know if there's so many apartments where
like
eventually everyone has to die in an
apartment
or somewhere somewhere or somewhere yes
but it's also like that's like
what if something like a battle or
something happened on a piece of land
does that affect if you built something
on it what about it is it because it's
just a personal feeling like it's a
house i'm trying to get like because
like in ikebukuro right right um
sunshine sunshine city yeah yeah
that's that was built on like a a pow
camp originally was it actually yeah
that's why they called it sunshine
because they were like let's rebrand it
to make it more happy well they weren't
going to call a
prisoner of war there's enough city pal
city
yeah
i think it was like
one of the that's why they renamed it to
be like sunshine because they wanted it
to be more really
holy [ __ ] i did not know that i believe
yeah i believe that it was a prisoner of
war camp before well and so you think
like i i don't go there and i'm like oh
[ __ ] man i think for me it's more more
so about like the recency of the event
right like because that's fair enough
you know
so
yeah recency and intimacy like you know
i just i'm sure there's a ton of land
all around us that was you know where
probably soldiers and you know people
just died right but it's like that
happened a very very very long time ago
whereas if someone you know just last
year got brutally murdered in this
living room then yeah i'd be a little
more uncomfortable it's just not a nice
thought knowing that i guess such an
atrocious thing happened in the very
spot
just murder by the way yeah
if people if someone die from natural
causes i'm okay with that my my concern
would be with murder or something right
it's like all right what if the guy got
murdered he was involved like gangs or
something dealing right i don't want
on their address book for it to be like
the guy that we hate lives here yeah and
then and then they come to my house
yeah i i would probably be asking a bit
more questions i'm not gonna you know if
it's if it's something like that or the
person was doing stuff like that i'd be
like all right this address is probably
not a great address
right yeah but i mean like i'd be okay
finding staying there for like temporary
or you know it's just like you know yeah
you stay there and you know you find out
it happens and like that's an
interesting story but like there's just
something about settling down or just
calling somewhere a home where something
like that has happened that would just
like it doesn't make me superstitious
it's just not a nice thought to have
where somewhere yeah for a place where
you should be completely comfortable
exactly from my permanent home i might
be a bit different towards it yeah
towards renting i don't i couldn't oh
yeah if it's renting
i'm i wouldn't even be okay with renting
to be honest yeah even if it's a steal
even if it's a but there's like
there's other ways to get a steal okay
i'm just like
[Music]
i guess i guess different question but
when does
you move into a new place okay
when does it start to actually feel like
your home and not just
a place of residence
if you've ever felt like that corner the
moment
the moment you've like
you've you've hit the wall and you've
chipped it and you're like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh that's my that's my problem
oh [ __ ] what
that's what
i chipped a good chunk of like the wood
in the frame when i was moving one of my
chairs right yeah and i was like oh [ __ ]
yeah i'm not going to get set my deposit
back now yeah god damn it it's literally
day one where your furniture is just a
little bit more heavy than you think
it's going to be your sofa you just want
to move the sofa a little bit and it's
just like you're just trying to nudge it
and then it just
and it just makes like that [ __ ]
scratch scratch you never you never see
it coming you're like i'm going to try
my best to not make the scratch but it's
always like just a little late like it
just slips a little bit more than you
think it's going to do i think you just
leave that screen i think for me the
moment where i know i've like really
settled down is when i am a hundred
percent aware of where everything is in
the house
because that you have that period where
you know you're first moving in you're
putting [ __ ] away in like cabinets and
yeah everything and then for a while
you're like
[ __ ] where was that thing again and you
just like look all around the house
because you don't know where it is but
where you're like
i know exactly where that really
specific thing is i feel that's when
it's like do you know what it is for me
it's really with me to for me it's when
i can switch on and off the lights
without having to look at them or try to
find them you know what i mean like you
move into a new house are you just like
where's where's the [ __ ] light switch
where's the [ __ ] light switch and
then you would live there for like like
a week or two or then you can like
[ __ ] ultra instinct this thing you
know like when you're when you enter the
like when you enter
yeah you hate it right especially like
if it's the living room and like there's
different switches depending on
which part of the living room and like
you live there for long enough and like
to me a home is when i want to turn on
that exact light i know the exact switch
that that i have to flick to turn on
that exactly right i don't know it's so
weird for me because
i've never been a guy who's like
i've never been a guy who's like
decorated his house a lot it's it's
weird right i've my room's my room's
always been like really bare it's it's
it's like a proper engineering room
which is i buy
everything exactly what i need to get
whatever i need done right i need a desk
i need a computer i need a chair you
don't buy non-functional things i i
didn't until i moved to japan and then i
realized how weird it is so i was like
i feel like like mark zuckerberg you
know i was like i was the same yeah i
was like i need to add personality to
this room i need to buy stuff to it like
fill this room up you know i've i've
always been that person where even when
i was back at home where i'm like if i
see an empty piece on my wall i'm just
like i can feel that oh no no no whether
that's a poster or a calendar or
anything i didn't i didn't decorate my
walls until jojo really yeah if you go
look at my first videos yeah for jojo so
my walls are like it's like a scientific
experiment here and it's like depressing
enjoy your change thing i guess it's
because like i guess before moving to
japan i've never i
the reason i never decorated anywhere
was because i'd always
think about the moment where i would
have to move out of that place right and
that the thought of having to like pack
things up and just take everything down
that seemed like such a
that seemed like just such a like such a
hassle that i was just like i'm going to
remove the hassle from myself even
though that's like years away from when
i need to move out right and then i just
never ended up decorating my room and
then i remember like the only reason i
started decorating it was because i was
on camera more so
so who would look weird if there was
nothing in the background
i guess if you're not on camera then
there's no need right yeah but i guess i
guess i'm wondering what it would be
like when you actually have your own
personal home that you're gonna i guess
your permanent residence that's uh
you're gonna you know you're gonna stay
in for like i guess years and years
right i'm putting that big [ __ ] hole
in the wall because i finally can
because i can't in my currently you know
i i wonder what the feeling is of being
like a true homeowner yeah and just like
i just want to get to that point where
i'm like you know what
i don't need this wall
entire wall take it down that's
i look at that and i'm just like that is
the end game that's that that is the end
game where i can do that where i'm like
wait i don't need permission to take
down this wall i just do it like right i
like in university you [ __ ] needed
permission to [ __ ] put posters up and
like the type of blue tack you use
like go from that to like breaking down
a wall was just like so alien to me like
you know what i want another room
give me another room
give me another room let's let's just
make let's just make these two rooms
into one
massive that just sounds so cool to me i
want a bonker that's what that one
that's the endgame for me